uh i just don't often perform my dates
on stage so
wow what a normie they're doing great
no i actually i think you're doing
fantastic grant and big stamp both agree
so far this is going well
i wouldn't even want to go on hiking on
a [ __ ] public date if you take me
hiking on a date i will kill you like
not if i kill you first no it won't
happen
[Music]
what a smooth talker
not a [ __ ]
so
it's good to know
so uh graham was running around this uh
you know room
like a golden retriever introducing
himself to everyone
great you're a very social guy yeah um
most of my personalities are uh i try to
you know introduce them to as many
people as possible i think uh audrey you
know maybe in a later date you can meet
the more introspective a little bit more
introverted ones they have some good
personality
okay let's drop the whole shtick with
the big magical personality
let's just be yourself we all know that
uh you're too boring to have such an
interesting mental illness
what do you do for a living
me uh i
work in cyber security sales so it's
been very busy lately with um overseas
wow that's good to know you have
multiple personality disorder
i don't think i want more from a
security guy than a mental illness
severe mental illness
audrey what do you think about this
weirdo what a what a psycho huh
um
i think that he's a good entertainer
he is
where are you from i'm from michigan is
she aware of michigan uh korean rapids
what are the dudes like up there
oh married married
[Music]
yeah judeo-christian
i feel like everybody just gets married
really young
so there's not a lot of options
there's
[Music]
you want to get married i'm bored
[Music]
let's go get
married uh can we get more lighting on
audrey that'd be nice i mean
i found the weird thing about the show
is that the women always sit right next
to the exit
the men always sit right weird or smart
i feel like men like to watch the door
and women like to be close to it you
know safety
for both
that way we can sneak up on you yeah
well i got long reach so you're gonna
have some problems with that
he's gone for the murder reference again
grant what's the longest relationship
you've been in uh a year actually you
only had two
girlfriends like officially
and the rest were boyfriends
perhaps
[Music]
yeah no just two girlfriends one was a
year in college and then one was
ended about six months ago we did it for
about eight months
we hate her
we're on your side
uh why did you break up with your
girlfriend from college did she get low
uh
grade point average or was she she was a
friend she was definitely the smart one
but she was just not having a good time
it was on spring break we broke up on
spring break and it was explosive did
you two like [ __ ] someone else
immediately
spring break
not quite she tried to uh erase the exes
off her hands at a club and was getting
kicked out for it and i like managed to
save her but she was just really
emotional the rest of the trip and i was
like
let's uh let's calm down a bit you have
no record and we're still drinking with
our friends oh wait she got kicked out
and that was like she couldn't handle it
she basically after she got kicked out
she couldn't
basically get it out of her head and
move on so not rejected by society
was funny though i didn't get that in
i didn't get that into the mind it was
carol oh did you show up late no
oh man i'm sorry about my tardiness men
are there anywhere usually men are early
you know we come fast
yeah
i got kicked out i've tried to bring a
gatorade into a country western bar in
chicago and the guy uh it doesn't fit
with our theme
ripped it out of my hands here's the
door guy and he's like you couldn't come
in here and i was like okay it was like
leave i was like i'll leave when you
give me my gatorade back and he's like
no
no i'm not [ __ ] leaving
and then he was like i stuck my dick in
it and i was like
that's a health health code violation
[Music]
implying that his penis is large i was
like thank you
he tells you stupid
he got shot and killed in the back of
that bar
whoa
chicago for you have you ever been
kicked out of laura andre or
gone to a fight
i'm not
audrey is a good person it should have
been i'm a good person
any of your friends gotten kicked out of
a bar and you had to rescue them
i feel like my life has been pretty tame
how old are you i'm 28.
oh what's the craziest thing you've done
i've never done anything very crazy you
haven't even gotten married
how are you going to get a divorce
how are you going to write your next
novel
what do you what do you do artistically
do you uh you know crochet or roller
roller skate
i do like cross stitch
cross stage what would you like what
would you make grant what do you think
he needs in his life a little home sweet
home or a straight suit
[Music]
maybe a heart because obviously this is
any love so
[Music]
it's ending in love well i i think she's
going down a very romantic path here
with me sounds like a very suicide
i mean i don't think she could stitch a
straight suit that could hold me though
but i'd like to see your truck
strong
what do you think about brent i mean i
think he's a great guy i think he's a
little uh you know happy and you know
he's always like hey guys what's up
you're trying to make it sad
do you think that'd be nice to be with a
guy that's like always
always like sort of happy all the time
i think it's good to have a full range
of emotions yeah grant
going to politics
she's going to be the new governor after
they kill the one that exists now
whitmer right
anyways are you vaccinated yes
nice grant are you vaccinated yeah um
but how many are you supposed to have
the question like three three
three that's the controversial part
there well two if you did that one one
box and then the booster
you didn't get boosted two for one speed
boosted
no i'm not boosted
you look vaccinated as [ __ ] yeah do you
go out and
get some vitamin d
take a lot of vitamins
[Laughter]
[Music]
audrey uh what's the longest
relationship that you've been in
about
what happened was it a spring break
incident or a bar fight no spring break
incident but um
it was you know approaching the end of
college and kind of felt like the next
step was on the horizon i didn't really
see that um you're like i'm graduating
from college and this relationship
i mean it wasn't quite like that but but
i uh yeah didn't really see a future so
you were like it's you
it's definitely
i feel like it was me i mean
i feel like uh
yeah like
nothing bad happened but i just wasn't
ready for the next step
what is the next step getting an
apartment or straight to marriage i feel
like probably like moving it together
yeah do you have pets or do you have a
roommate currently i don't have a
roommate i do have a fish
fish
i inherited him from former roommate she
kind of abandoned him
um so she dated the fish
is there a movie about that
oh so that's water ban or something
uh so you have a fish is there a way to
get this air on even
my nipples are super hard right now mine
are gone
my penis isn't small enough
yeah well it's getting more shrinkage in
there
so you have a fish
in michigan who's feeding you right now
uh well they can go a few days so you
know
a few days yeah
hopefully he's not done he did like a
practice fast
really
[Music]
[Music]
because they are um
they're fighting fish
they fight each other
yeah if you all were fish what kind of
fish would you be oh my god grant gets
his pickup lunch from the
i'll be internet biggest whale in the
ocean
don't call yourself a whale
um
i have three bloody whales are
technically fish whales are mammals
um where's okay [ __ ] off
dating with an autistic person
um
i would probably be a marlin because i
got a really long thin dick
i
[Music]
like tic tacs
what kind of genitalia do you prefer in
a relationship
i'm using this for a studio
that's a good start um
luckily we have plenty of that here
where why are you here are you just like
partying for the i mean are you just
like doing a sewing circle for the
weekend for
with friends just real cash
i'm just doing a solo trip
so much yeah free solo
showing my crazy slime yeah
well this is your crazy side
that's cool honestly that's pretty
[ __ ] brave to go on a trip by
yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah this is awesome baby
we [ __ ] each other
uh i've hit up for a threesome
whoa
twice the other night well by the same
couple but still
they're very persistent
that still counts on your record yeah i
think it does
but you rejected them
yeah i started laughing because um
i've never just been blatantly asked
before and i got
nervous
[Music]
julia roberts get
for a pretty woman
over the years the whole
total we'll figure it out she got richer
gear you put it on your instagram for
how much to book amy schanker for uh i
feel like i'd do a threesome for free if
i liked him
sex usually works
like five grand
i'm really good
i think we can make that happen because
we can put that out there we can all
pull together five grand you could have
a giant [ __ ] 20 something right now
so if you're gonna it's per two people
it's another five grand like
how many
what is your guys income
i think we can make this happen to go
[ __ ] me
oh it's the new only fans go [ __ ] me
you heard him here first let's start
that one
[Music]
i'll be over here
audrey any threesomes in michigan or is
it more traditional over there
um more traditional i think
parties
a lot of missionary trips to uh
i can't speak for everyone my own
personal experience is been more
traditional but
yeah well you know michigan isn't known
for their wild sexual escapades but it's
like i need to go [ __ ] let me go to
dearborn
are there any dark secrets about
michigan we should know like
any
you're all actually dead
[Laughter]
you were saying like male genitalia you
know the up is nice but maybe you should
check out grant's lp if you know what i
mean lower peninsula
times that is sexual harassment all
right
[Music]
we want to see
[Music]
there's just one more
we gotta switch over during last time we
always rotate
thank you so you want to rotate
okay let's rotate it
we're not a rotate audrey's gonna come
back give it up for audrey she was a
great sport
[Applause]
she's not gonna sue us
all right we got
audrey you signed up again or is there
another audrey
there's no i put your name back in the
box
well you want to come up
laurel's coming up
audrey's taking a break
and welcome to the stage dylan jarvoo
give it up for dylan
laurel
how are you doing hi i'm doing great
here we are right
i love it
uh my name is dylan
i'm a
scorpio typo negative
i try to donate at least once a month
[Music]
i love you where are you from thank you
i'm from austin i love virgo
[Music]
um like hyde park area hyde park where
do you live now i live on south lamar
not specifically yeah
yeah that question just made me
uncomfortable
so
what do you do for work
i'm in the energy industry energy
okay okay then renewable
[Music]
enough okay
i work for um
i work for bank of america and i'm very
nervous right now so you're so pretty
and i love your jacket and um
and time
give it up for dylan
breathing heavily into the money
that's honestly the
[Applause]
and where is
she hopefully she's doing well um it
lasted like
a little bit longer than this
and um i think she works at google so
she's probably doing pretty good well
luckily we could google her
if i know where she is laura you're in
the energy industry yeah what do you
think about this weirdos energy
i don't know he seems curious about me
yeah
i like how you're like
asking about her and then you're like
thank you
finally yeah you know like it's uh hard
because you know some dudes they just
talk about themselves the whole time
yeah i don't have a whole lot to talk
about
it's got low self-esteem which is
not as comforting as you think it is
a lot of insoles
but uh
dylan you're from jacksonville yes sir i
recently performed there you ever been
to the vice star veterans memorial arena
i did i saw someone get punched in the
face there like a year ago it's a great
time hello was it during spring break
and did she have x's on her hands she
did she did she did there's a lot of
thicker eggs punched her in the face but
i love it there man
um i grew up in the same neighborhood as
learned skinner so you know
yeah but like 30 years afterwards right
yeah yeah definitely
so
that's kind of cool are you a singer can
you send us a song can you sing laurel a
little love song
by leonard skinner
yeah i could do justin bieber do you
guys want to just a beaver song
he's standing on
[Music]
is helpful in that song
laurel what's the last day you went on
probably like a week ago
you recently were in a relationship
right yeah how did you
because you were like i'm single now
[Music]
yeah i didn't say that all the single
ladies
if you want a dude you can either go
outside
anywhere
or just come here
[Music]
what uh what happened uh how did it
start how did it end how was the middle
it started on bubble um
and then it lasted a month until the
kids conversation came up
and
i want kids and i didn't
i don't have any kids yeah they would
figure that out later you know what i'm
saying no you figured out now she's not
wasting another [ __ ]
[Music]
maybe try blinking more
why didn't you guys like just have that
in your profile i want kids or i don't
like it did his profile say you didn't
want kids
you're like i just looked at that yeah
wow what if that month was your fault
i've never been to welding school but i
will have a children with you
welding school yeah
that's the only thing a lot of guys who
go to welcome school have a lot of kids
so that's that's a hell of a lot
leap that was a hell of a leap
uh you went from bumble to mumble
this guy mumbles
but he was a welder yeah holy [ __ ] he
made a lot of
money guess that correct water welder
what
underwater yeah yeah
under water
if you said you made a lot of money i'm
like that [ __ ] was underwater
was it a space
i'm sad i'm surprised you could have
weld the relationship together
you are just really trying to make these
work tonight
i've been hanging out with tony
and you work in
energy
what do you do though
i'm just a project manager um don't say
just
you control people
yeah like also
[Music]
so like
bachelor of bachelor in paradise would
you which one
i don't watch it on the date it's nice
isn't it allowed yeah can we do that
still it's like a
elk during mating season
hey so um
have you been to jackalopes on the
riverside area
jackalopes was on 36. never mind
guys
i think there was a jackalope oh did you
say 36.30
what's so special about jackalopes i
don't know i just thought is that your
house i just saw it in my head sorry
guys what's your perfect date
here we go all right silker sitting
around just looking at the stars and
whatever
and then
no
there's more
and then
then we go downtown um
homeless guy offers me money i give it
to him and you watch and you're like
and then
nevermind
[Music]
um no
i don't know okay so zilker lay on a
little thing
you know blanket and then
[Laughter]
i never
thought but
we sit together and just look it up and
we're just like physically what are we
right and we just stare at each other
and then um
and then we go home
that's about it
separately
yeah probably
do you know about constellations
oh yeah
i mean i know they exist yeah
they're definitely there i there's the
belt or ryan's belt i don't want to know
him though i just wanted to know if you
knew about that yeah yeah they were
there
they're there
what's your favorite constellation
[Music]
what's your perfect date laurel
that that sounds nice oh come on but
usually not a bar definitely a
restaurant yeah and a walk after
yeah but i get hit on
the most at silver park
yoga
really like at least twice every time
it's crazy do you have an accent that's
not austin
when if i hang around different people i
pick it up really fast she's talking
like dylan jarvo
stop hanging out with him people are
gonna think you're trying to murder them
that's true
so what what what pose do you think is
is the most likely to get hit on like is
there something that you do maybe at a
water break
because it seems like it's hard to hit
on people at a park like that'd be the
last place i'd do that
what are they saying what's their pickup
line
volleyball
are you from here can i get directions
it's a direction directions to when he
says directions to your heart
that was terrible
and then an hour ago i was there and a
guy walks up to me and goes
is it intentional that you're dressed up
just like the kite that's right next to
you like are you on the same group
together
because i was wearing like this doing
yoga and it was like a red fish with
blue yeah that common move where you
dress up like a kite to go to sofa
i'm so sorry to every woman in the crowd
that's terrible
that actually made my day because it was
just [ __ ] weird and then he literally
walks away because i didn't smile
you're supposed to smile
whenever i smile
it's like that's my pickup line
i think you existing is the pickup
me existing
thank you yeah yeah that was my pickup
my parents paid a lot of money for
braces when i was in eighth grade
is it working
they didn't pay for a therapist
i wouldn't be here if they did that
let me see yours
okay
can i give you one suggestion
[Music]
can you will you just cut your mustache
hair a little shorter
because
what do you think
yeah
kiss
all right
[Music]
doesn't look like pubes yet
[Music]
would you date me if i didn't have a
beard or anything would you do you think
you could do that i don't think
are you asking how this could happen
yeah
and you
you sort of look like my brothers
[Music]
yeah she is from texas
is he doing well all right i'm good
what's he do
oh he is a computer and phone tech
so
we also fix your phone
call laurel's brother go find her at
zilker park and that's for tech repair
get a blanket i realize it's a blanket
get a blanket guys
is that what you rob your victims in
a question
that's a real question no i do not have
any victims
mr thompson
wow
what do you like about jacksonville what
do you miss about old j-town
man i miss
the jean shorts
i miss cath tattoos
i miss the beach
and everything have you guys ever been
to florida
donuts
i know i just miss it being easier
everything was a lot easier there but
hitting
i dated a guy that had a half tattoo
once and it was
who's that cartoon that twirls in a
circle
yeah
playing baseball i was like
no
everything's easier there that's that's
a really concerning thing's easier what
does that mean like what it's just you
could just do whatever if you want and
then nothing matters
yeah
so as a man in florida you can do
whatever you want that's what no i mean
not like that
but it's just it's just not you don't
have to try it sorry i don't know
it's a small town
yeah yeah yeah it's a small town but
it's a city at the same time
[Music]
yeah it's a city built around a nascar
track yeah well that's daytona beach but
you know it's flawless it's kind of just
you know it's coming up
did you like it yeah you like this yeah
it's a great arena would you ever go to
jacksonville with me if i'm like my
parents live there
[Music]
you know they have they have a house
there you can meet them they're very
nice people what's the population of
jacksonville
it's it's pretty big it's like a million
but it goes
it's the biggest city in the united
states like land wide it's just really
far everyone's right wait do you mean
acreage
anchorage
acreage
all the swamp you could want
yeah yeah yeah everything's far
everything's really far so you're gonna
drive you gotta have some gas mileage
do you wanna go there sometime
why do you want my responsibility this
is like my parents are gonna to meet you
eventually
they're very nice we've got a bunch of
dogs i feel like i'm at zelka park right
now
i don't like the end of this date
i would probably
what's your what's your out on a date
what do you do
phone call
sick
[Music]
anyways the next guy is going to be so
much better
dylan you're doing great you're weird
not everyone is like you
you want to go on another date
[Applause]
[Music]
can we get the uh
the ac turned off
we got a couple ladies on stage it's
cody
cody and laurel
yes i know i have no real social life so
i to experience a show's life
yes that's sad
and well this is more entertaining
oftentimes than a real social life so it
is still a lot more fun because even if
the date sucks i have a great story to
tell we'll do the next date
um so you said you're from austin
i am also from austin it's nice to meet
another austinite every time i've done
this i think it's always been someone
who is from
someone else
and
i don't know i just i like local people
because i like to know that we know the
same kind of things
those
routes around town i don't know what do
you think
park restaurants
do you say store time downtown in like
uh central austin or do you spend time
in suburbs
i appreciate how even though during
awkward
time periods he still feels like he's a
little bit comfortable with it
not even facing her michael very tall
how tall are you uh six one in the
morning hello there
paul bunyan
six what
in the morning in the morning i usually
lose an inch but you have to do
[Music]
it's a weird thing about
height and compression i stretch when i
sleep because i lay down flat
during the day gravity kind of smooshes
you do you do uh
you measure yourself throughout the day
are you made of real bones
this guy's just jello as a human being
he's just flopping around
a lot i also do yoga
so you like talking to locals because
they know the same routes around town
what's your favorite round around town
what's your favorite street to drive
honestly my favorite streets drive on us
tomorrow i know it sounds yeah
yeah
we got a little crowd over here they're
congress wow i did not think that was
going to be a hot button question
i didn't either
i've done a lot of driving and so
when i have to go somewhere i get very
frustrated when someone drives and uh
what i perceive is the incorrect way
it may not be the wrong way but i'm
going to call rob slow yes
i [ __ ] hate the drivers in this
[ __ ] city i'm gonna tell you that
right now they're all trash
money it's so slow
you don't have to stop the whole way at
a stop sign that's a suggestion
especially
they make eye contact with you and
they're like how are you
there parker
nice time of day
so are you she's used to the subways
that's why she was late today yeah they
were late
uh you like the bell pack
no pack
expressway
i mean the parks are under construction
a great expressway
airport boulevard some of the great
routes around town i thought when you
said i like a local i thought that was
just code for white person that's what i
thought
this is gonna go real racist real fast
not like some of these out of towners
the jews
always showing up late
uh laurel was jewish i should say that's
[Music]
uh laurel what's your favorite uh route
to get to zulkier
7th lamar
[Music]
and they got like rocks
rocks
is really what you should call it
because that's what it is
but what's what's the difference between
it being a park and just a
big thing and i think
the skyline okay what do they do with
the funding again like what's in the
park that's what i haven't been to the
park it's just a bunch of grass
there's there's grass there's a trail
around the grass there's trees there's
it because i was the last time i went i
was probably in the sequel you were
banned
you have to stay 200 feet away right
um
you've never been to zilter i don't
think i've been to zilker we need to
take amy to zulker yeah
do you guys want to go paddle boarding
on a date with me
hans the crowd and the two of you
absolutely all right i've never been
meet us at zilker
tonight
let's look at the constellations on a
blanket on the paddleboard
it still isn't so bad
cuddy what's your ideal date
um
uh would like to eat dinner somewhere
i'd like to
actually probably like like see a movie
before dinner so you guys can talk about
dinner
what kind of date do you think cody
would be into just looking at his
bandana right now
probably like a festival yeah
[Music]
concert yeah fish do you do shrooms
once a while
six months
yeah
okay wow such a long time how did you do
it yeah um what's what's your favorite
what drug do you guys think you could do
together what drugs do you guys think we
go together with you guys
it is being filmed we won't
hopefully you're pro-legalization yeah
and if not i mean honestly you deserve
to get taken down by this video no
uh what uh what's your political
affiliation i mean obviously he's a
[ __ ] liberal
hipster [ __ ]
you look like you're dressed like a real
estate agent you know you might be a
small business
trump supporter
no i went to my grandma's birthday party
so
[Music]
dress nice for grandma
that's nice she invited you
she doesn't have many more left like all
the time i wear collars when i go visit
my grandmother
[Music]
did you guys come here together from her
birthday no
would your grandfather have a nice
birthday
yes how old is she 75 75 she's still
young i guess compared to my girl she's
86 87.
your grandma should [ __ ]
yeah it's okay
i'm bored with this date
[Applause]
audrey back up here
there's no more dudes left
you want to go on a date with laurel
sure let's
let's do this oh good
that's great
people to be lesbians no let's just
teach the men how to talk
good
instead of teaching
you guys
let's see the two women on the show
together
alas
hi
nice to meet you through you
on truth
what what's your preferred
day situation
uh first date probably a couple drinks
short and simple
yeah second date probably dinner
and drinks and then third date probably
like an activity
yeah slowing fun
i like that the first day it's a very
short commitment so you can't spend too
much time you feel
sad
that i should do that more
but
i also don't have a fellow board
so easy
like she said you can just sit on it
[Music]
when you're confused just sit on it
[Music]
i wasn't here for your first
date
i'm more excited i'm more insane to you
than you have to
i'm leave out of towners so a little
different than the last date but i'm
just here on a trip
and time
give it up for laurel and audrey
[Applause]
the minorities in the audience
um you're from out of town so you don't
know about south florida do you
nice
what did you do there
saturday night saxony
saxon pubs
what did you do there um i have a friend
from michigan who moved here um and he's
in multiple meetings i guess
oh it's a music spot yeah so his one of
his bandmates was playing in his other
band um
and that was cool that's so funny yeah
what type of music
it was like
yeah it was good um do you know the name
of the band
well you know i'm sure they were great
you know you don't remember their name
but
maybe they were better than that they
were i wish i remembered their name
because i didn't like the music i
thought i could advertise them but
okay
i have commitment issues
after this i'd recommend wtf icehouse
for live music
yeah
that's on south or sixth street
yeah it's uh it's a good bar um
so you uh
you okay
isn't this an all-nighter for you
all nighter
because you were like messaging me on
instagram at like 4 30am
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
that's when uh we got back home from
dinner at the steakhouse in jacksonville
4 30. yeah
um
[Music]
it was at 1 30 the ufc got out we got
there the whole staff was there waiting
but enough about me
yeah the whole place stayed open for joe
wrote and mostly me but
yeah yeah
i was there he was there joe joe was
there too they like to sit at the table
so it was a three-hour dinner and then
you started just messaging her i just
started messaging her he went about the
time i was like please come out
with me shout out more women yeah yeah
concerned
yeah
yeah settlers
how do you play little settlers
i have played a few times of course
you're from michigan this is the whitest
place ever
uh
what's your strategy sheep weed brick
rock
my strategy is to hopefully get to place
my my fur i
is just anywhere other than um at that
table
can't stand that game
yeah it's so logical
i think that's the problem
so obviously uh you guys are straight uh
you guys want to get another dude up
here and watch a dude date whoa
yeah
let's get a dude how about this guy
right here with the lanyard one
[Applause]
let's get another chair
let's watch this asian man get grilled
oh no there's no mic um
[Music]
very complex a lot of ducks people a lot
of dutch people very tall
i feel like yeah
yeah um holland michigan is like 40
minutes away so everybody
do you work at uh austin energy or
no but i'm thinking about applying there
they're freaking awesome they're awesome
my next name is the vp of it over there
[Music]
well if i give you a specific name
you'll figure out where exactly where i
live
well i don't know if you know but in
austin if you look at the tcat you can
actually look up anybody's name and find
out where they live
it's a really weird thing about owning
properties
that's a really weird thing about
learning broadband in austin
thank you for that information
most of us are renters we are
millennials
uh but that's good to know i wish you
had revealed that information after cody
left the room but at least dylan jarvo's
not here
for your shirt
about how he owns a house
justin is used to uh hanging out with
successful asians
he's not used to you know these poor
wives
[Music]
i grew up in a small town called tomball
where uh
a lot of rednecks we were a family as
the first asian family in the 10 or 6
house
and the fun fact about my town is that
we had the ku klux klan better going on
so did you say fun
the fun thing about that
yep used to see that how does the kkk
feel about asians i've always wondered
you know it's really funny because they
didn't know how to define it i wanna
know what your definition of fun and fun
they had no definition of what an asian
person was they'd never seen one before
they thought i was just messy
so and it didn't help that i also
enjoyed it
so small
there you go
and uh my babysitter was in fact uh
lived in a trailer kkk
they were actually yeah not so i didn't
know that i'm glad your parents vetted
them
they were german
and as we all know they're all nazis
those journeys
is that why you're implying that i think
you're in the asian kkk
[Music]
[Music]
that's crazy to just know your family on
slaves
[Music]
thank you for the third amendment
my personal favorite i hate quartering
soldiers
can't stand it
they just get to come in
[Music]
so what do you think about this
beautiful tall asian man usually they're
not like this
well look at me
and then you'll get a good sense of
what you're looking at
just stronger
really and he's married too so you know
he's good at bed no he's just married
again
it's hard to tell asians really keep
things closer
too
she is yes she's korean
[Music]
yeah
i messaged her last night at 4am
audrey
have you ever dated an asian man before
oh i've been armed oh and what was he
like nice
yeah
boring i think i mean
i'm not in a relationship with him now
but
so obviously he wasn't good enough
he was uh you know probably good at math
but not very good at uh making eye
contact
driving
it's been a while so i don't really
remember but
well
another chance to uh redeem yourself for
the asian race redeem
i mean what what do you think what kind
of date would you go on with justin
audrey is the do you think he'd be into
basketball if anyone says [ __ ] silker
park again
it's too many dates then
well he's married so probably wouldn't
go on a date
or a threesome
how many years five thousand how many
years have you been we just got married
[Music]
wait
okay that's good to know
um so uh would you uh you know like
you'd be in a polyamorous relationship
that would be a possibility
with another man
yeah
it wouldn't be the first time
one one of the reason guys no no i got
hit on by a guy
at the bar not too long ago but um
the best case was actually uh
i'm not gonna name name but he's a very
tall area because i will know where he
is
very tall director adrian brody um
[Music]
festival and he invited me to
[Music]
hey dude
you're the tallest asian man i've ever
met
props you look good job and uh that was
it
later on i don't know how he got my
instagram and my facebook he messaged me
on social media he goes hey
are you
jude
director of parasite
[Music]
first class to palm springs for a huge
party there for doriano oh palm's brain
is just happened to you
like all the time or is that
um i think i put myself out there for
situations like this kind of like what
you do he's on grindr
you know it yeah
justin uh how did you meet your wife
airbnb
it was
are you a predatory landlord
no i'm not californian
[Music]
okay
[Music]
and the landlord the landlady messaged
me and goes hey justin there's gonna be
two cute asian girls coming in you
should date them and i was like both of
them was like why not
yeah just california and then uh
and she's like yeah they're little cute
two little cute sweet taller kids you
should date them
dude i'm not dating young college kids
so i ignored them for three days and
then one day i saw them on breakfast uh
in the
kitchen
and uh we started talking i learned that
they were locked into the kitchen
yeah yeah i just sometimes occasionally
make my way to the kitchen towel
yeah just they're naked
[Music]
i'm sorry yeah i just see you there
sorry
you're the tallest asian man i've ever
met and then they got your instagram and
well i also used to do tour guides in
austin so i used i gave them a tour of
boston and welcomed those because i
learned that they were actually phd
students that's a good lesson for all
the men out there first get them into
your home then surprise them in the
kitchen
where all the weapons are what if
they're what if they were just like
english majors would you be like
your phd all right i don't judge anyone
based on energy i got broken up for
because of education so oh really you're
too smart no they're not makes not happy
yeah we're like that i'm a jew i get it
oh my family's the third jewish though
there you go a third how did that work
um
we have a lot of family members
jewish
but like yuri i also made a joke about
axe murdering them when we went to a
threesome bridge how'd they like it
they uh they laughed kind of like
[Music]
but in asia that's like a belly laugh
he's just killed in front of asians
so laurel what do you uh
what would you uh
think of going on a date with justin
where would you go somewhere with uh
high ceilings probably
i don't know probably you feel the
basketball
that sounds funny if you don't want if
y'all are actually interested i do take
people out for real dates so i'll take
you off paddleboarding i go to trc all
the time sure wait what were you doing
at sundance
uh
i got invited to i'm involved in the
austin film festival here our phone yeah
and so i i got invited out to
the group
i'd like to go there for my first date
with you so
uh has some stiff competition is she
here she's not here right now she lives
in houston
what do you live here and she lives in
houston yeah
she's really smart she works at md
anderson she's a
phd poster what do you what's your guys
like together schedule look like
every other weekend
you see your wife every other weekend
custody over your wife
uh that's cool audrey what do you think
about uh this weird
relationship that he's like seeing her
like once every two weeks
i don't think it's that weird he's
probably masturbating a lot
it's true
you are gonna you guys are gonna be
together until you die if you keep this
arranged
what an easy marriage
it's almost like not being married at
all
fourteen days you see each other two out
of the fourteen yeah maybe you could
have a mission you see each other four
days a month
i mean often uh either i go there she
comes here and then sometimes we'll see
each other at each other's places for
like a week or something
nice
surprise you're in the kitchen again
remember this baby
did you spend more time together when
you dated
yeah i mean obviously the airbnb we
started out by living in the same house
so um yeah
we've lived together for then you could
grow apart
yeah yeah it's the nature of dating in
the professional world where you have to
relocate it sometimes
yeah luckily you're rich in asian so you
can travel whatever you want oh is she
just rich
pictures okay mister i'm flying on a
private jet i did fly in a private jet
it's really cool
[Music]
[Music]
what does your wife do
she is a
she's a cancer survivor research
researcher
um so she we research as cancer
survivors yes researches cancer
survivors she's a person that survived
cancer she's also here
[Applause]
[ __ ] him and marry his wife
have you met laurel or audrey
both singled recently
so uh which one of you want to go on a
one-on-one date with justin
no i don't know i want to see two guys
go on a date
okay
two guys i'm serious y'all i'll i'll
actually set up you with like a friend
group and actually go and do stuff seems
like you're an active person
that's not married people come back to
michigan we can hang out and like go to
you know bars and haunted
music
can i bring my paddle boat to a bar if
you want to seriously come board
hopefully
they all come first
[Music]
the ones that come next
on stage
[Music]
all right let's get this guy up here
laura you want to go on a date with this
guy
they're both coming up all right we
already saw it
i kind of want to see people that
actually want to [ __ ] each other
i don't really know get those two get
those two guys
hey why don't you two come on
all right let's get a real live couple
up here okay i'm sorry guys we'll get
you up next time
[Music]
what a chaotic show this is it is you
gotta get more winning i see how i see
the
i see why they're together they just
both walk through the garage
[Music]
couple that gets on stage together stays
together give it up for this couple
they're going on a date
[Music]
about start from the beginning so i'll
actually tell them the background we met
at 7 11 i was in the corner
to be fair it's where i met most of my
girlfriends i truly asked her to buy me
drinks i didn't say crap no it could
have been worse
could have been worse i mean red bull
and drinks it got worse immediately
afterwards to be fair was blacked out
completely yeah so you still want to go
for the weekend
yep
[Music]
yeah so that was us um no but i truly
met him in a 7-11 and uh asked him to
buy me drinks wait can you guys just
reenact the conversation and show don't
tell yeah i don't know that i was
speaking coherently but it was something
like hey you wanna give me a rebel we
should probably let them know we both
were seeing other people at the time oh
i was not gonna include that's a [ __ ]
thanks a lot that's cool yeah we both
had so it started out as a platonic
request for a sugar-free red bull for
you maybe and then i was gonna give you
a hand on the bathroom at least
fast forward a few hours
i mean i definitely was but um yeah so
then we ended up at my apartment
platonically as
except for when you bit my neck and grab
my balls it started to get less platonic
that's totally platonic for me
remind me not to let you hang out with
men ever again
that's fair um but yeah no we were at
our apartment and we always say it in a
really sweet way like our friend
introduced us because technically he's
the one that took me black out to the
7-eleven so
we stayed this way our friend slash
mutual coke dealer uh
[Music]
they embody the spirit of our city are
you guys really too spies
we are from the ira staying here to
infiltrate american ways clearly
are you guys really dumb so no one
catches the one
who is irish
he dyes his beard red and his hair is
not resting at all
that's not false your beard is red your
hair is not never died any part of me
ever oh i agree
with you
you guys are ready for that trailer park
yeah
at the trailer park how long have we
been dating buddy
[Laughter]
uh that was in december and then
we started when we broke up with our
actions
immediately to be together in
i love the way february
she grabs my balls yeah i gotta keep
this girl how do you grab just the balls
it's well you go from behind yeah
start looking start low and work your
way up
cradling
wait so you're just a ball lady and you
like your balls and then it was like
that was it it was love at first round
i was blacked out so i don't remember
but he loved it
i love when they don't remember is she's
saying basically
are you dating like what's the system so
we have two separate living situations i
live kind of north by the domain she
lives on
[Music]
that's funny because you very much seem
like the domain and she very much seems
like south lamar
no way no way
yeah it seemed like saxon saxon probably
um i've been here for 18 years and she's
been here for a lot less than
four years four
yeah her grandma's sister offered
it's true she literally said if you
don't [ __ ] my will
you've never been more turned on by an
eight-year-old
[Music]
yeah
in
you know that's basically where we hang
out on the corner right it's like the
silver park of something like that
you know we put down a blanket and just
wait for someone to give us a red bull
and then we give our hands out to the
bathroom i thought those are just
homeless people
next time
don't pass it up don't be sleepy now
yeah
but just don't go to 7-eleven offer
people red bulls
so where do you guys see this going
i mean hopefully back to south lamar
tonight off the rails and i imagine
do either you want kids
i gotta get this out of the way yeah
sure no
laurel shout out no kids so you all
wanna know an
[Music]
my mother's last name is martin so we're
from yeah we're just not gonna check we
don't know but we're not gonna have kids
he's dating his mother
i love how you guys are wearing this
shirt that describes where you're from
did you plan that or you like people
even know
we don't do a lot of planning to be
honest so
he's failing upwards that's yes
is that a compliment to me or no i think
that's an insult to both of us
saddle up next
[Music]
cheers
[Music]
so bad for your neighbors
what position do you guys like the most
i mean i prefer a street corner but yeah
i mean it's 7 11. it's kind of like the
weather in austin you know give it a few
minutes it'll change that's fair that's
also fair
a lot of energy a lot of sweating a lot
of uh always cardio he never knows which
means he's gonna get but it's true it's
the good thing about dating someone with
multiple personalities it's like
a different girlfriend every day
did you have you uh figured his butthole
yet
i mean not by his choice but yeah i
never i never walk in front of her
just to be clear
got his head on his head
[Music]
no
[Music]
my will that's the devil's wrong more so
it's kind of [ __ ] either way
[Music]
we driving you to the bottle
that's fair you guys seem like a wild
couple like you guys uh you know like
have the most fun you know like people
are always like wow this couple is like
really you know loud yeah it's usually
when we're like [ __ ] next to them and
they're like god i wish they would be
quiet but true
oh this was a nice 7-eleven
so you get to [ __ ] public a lot and
then you're just go with the flow
um wait a minute i mean i can't question
anywhere public not public it's fine he
lets me get away with a lot when's the
last time you two [ __ ] in public
it's been hours
in the bathroom or in the patio well
coconut club's nice because they have
the bathrooms that you can shut the door
and walk behind you so it's gonna feel
privacy so that's where is that really
public i don't know
yeah if you didn't have sex in there and
you didn't do it right i don't think
they can invite you to bring multiple
people together that's true
right you guys are missing us
she's been there for five grand we heard
about it
so yeah i mean do you guys ever think
about three sums or
more than me i think
really it's usually the other way do you
want two days but i have to hide my
enthusiasm we have an afterparty
[Music]
[Music]
uh well please keep us updated yeah you
guys have like a joint instagram
if you totally see we should maybe but
no i feel like grant said what was it
only [ __ ] earlier
trying to get in on grant's new site so
hopefully be early investors well go
[ __ ] us is what you i think that might
be a better
if it's more explanatory
it's true
how much can we charge per month can we
quit our jobs well do we have to get
[Music]
do you wear your cowboy hat when you're
[ __ ] him
yeah pretty much
always standard reverse cowgirl
anyways i'm getting too horny um
does it close behind you and walk the
door
yeah don't don't worry about them
right in that parking lot
it's not a 7-11 no
that's where people get shot but like do
you pay extra moonshiners
like back home we get that for free so
you get food shine for free that's
because y'all make it your toilet
that's okay it's an excluded or paid
extra like just curious here i like this
extra yeah
[Music]
yeah in oklahoma you guys would have met
by a toilet like dude
he said we would have met at a toilet in
oklahoma but we met we made it to
7-eleven it's not yeah that's pretty
much hold the nose
all it takes was a two fifty dollar
ribbon until we were done well you guys
are you know like a beautiful couple and
you know
hot as [ __ ] yeah
and she puts the ass in class no doubt
she uh very hot so like please [ __ ]
yourselves more and like let us know
instagram
um but uh thank you for coming on and uh
thank you for being part of the show
[Applause]
they're gonna go [ __ ] in public now
do not follow them
just clean up
[Music]
that was that was a wild couple
that's why
they're either gonna die together
in love or die together because they
killed each other
but they're i don't think either of them
is ever going to be seen without the
other one ever again yeah this is like
donald trump jr over here yeah
but that was like gross
they linked each other's tongues
they're hot um
thank you guys for uh
coming up here uh
more material in the spank bank now
um but uh we had a good show we had a
great time we got up for amy
[Applause]
uh yeah
i'm recording an album this summer holy
[ __ ]
amy shanker one of the funniest
comedians thanks
she's hilarious she's uh passing all the
clubs in new york check her out
and buy her album and all that yeah
do you want to promote
um i was on a private jet yesterday
yeah
the king of austin you know
go look at his instagram follow hans on
instagram dj nonstand take out your
faults
sign up for my seminar to see how to win
um i'm a winner
sign up for your chance to win a plane
i'll take you as my plus one next time
you got a plus one i didn't ask oh
yeah but um check me out on tinder
uh that was the show
thank you guys so much and uh stay tuned
for the uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
yes
[Music]
okay so you really